monsieur le micro c'est là c'est non
parce que
ces eaux je fais le beau mesdames
messieurs après un déjeuner de travail
extrêmement positif avec mes collègues
de l'europe des six 9,9 contre 10,6 très
simple capitulons il y avait là roberto
hans car stand by halle ça fait 4 et
john romita fait 6 octobre et moi ça
fait
neuf ou alors on va déjà et de travail
extrêmement positif avec mes collègues
de l'europe des neuf déjeuner de travail
qui a duré plus de cinq heures et demi
et qui est d'ailleurs un des plus
réussis que nous ayons fait depuis six
ans eh bien je suis en mesure de vous
dire aujourd'hui que tous les problèmes
de l'europe qu'ils soient alimentaires
agricoles vinicole ou encore ceux du vin
sans oublier ceux des liqueurs et de ce
qu'on nomme à tort le pinard ont été
abordés tiens à redire à tous et
pessimistes voyaient l'europe agonisante
voir morte
eh bien je leur dis et le redis qu'elle
est repartie l'europe comme en 40
attendez le problème des laitages
hollandais dans le mois forces d'élite 1
oui oui ça ils ont été évoqués durant ce
déjeuner de travail
je crois que cette fois monsieur van
houtte hervé qu'a compris la mimolette
ne passera pas moi j'ai repris 4 fois du
camembert ans le marchand avec du beurre
breton et ça ne nous a pas impressionné
outre mesure que monsieur van houtte
ehrbeck pour se venger et but avec le
ministre danois de bouteille de schnaps
qu'un la belgique violent l'allemagne et
moi même avons immédiatement répliqué en
visant neuf bouteilles de pommard
rétablissant ainsi l' équilibre vital au
sein de la communauté
le ministre
le problème des hormones dans la
volaille anglaise écouter alors ça va
vous dire parce que personne n'en a pris
1 lorsque le poulet au porridge est
arrivé là tout le monde rien que la
sauce déjà ça avait l'air pire que les
hormones mais comme le ministre allemand
qui a eu le courage de prendre une
cuisse et qui dit quelque chose de ses
ministres
donc non très sincèrement il s'est
contenté de recracher en proposant que
la grande bretagne soit exclu du marché
commun avez vous abordé les problèmes de
limites de pêche de mai qui les limite
de la pêche au quai pour la langoustine
monsieur voilà petit 2 millions de
millionnaires avec que dénonce julien
n'avait pas emmené je ne peux pas vous
dire et la viande à écouter alors ça je
tiens à le répéter encore une fois
j'espère que ce sera la dernière il n'y
a aucun problème de viol dans le marché
commun écouter lorsqu'on mange avec un
bon appétit et un bon coup du rhône qui
veut me dire la différence qu'il ya
entre un mouton anglais une vache
allemande ou un fort italien qui sinon
ceux qui veulent casser le rap up en
jouant la carte de la différence écoutez
nous étions là et neuf ministres et je
vous rappelle que nous sommes des
ministres spécialistes nous étions là
neuf ministres et bien nous avons
dégusté les viandes
aucun de nous n'a pu dire ni de quel
pays il de quel animal cette viande
provenait et tout ça pourquoi parce que
nous voulons une europe égale pour tous
même pour les animaux
et pour les animaux aussi
à la passe à une très bonne proposition
du ministre olic strasbourg voix qui
s'est tellement régalé avec le curry
d'agneau qu'il a proposé que l'a proposé
que l'aide
entre-temps le marché commun ce à quoi
nous avons tous dit d'accord y'a pas
longtemps la condition que l'on supprime
les crédits pour la culture des choux de
bruxelles qu'on a tous trouvé mais qu'on
a mangé quand même égaré par politesse
et de politesse et de france dans la
ville ou dans laquelle on se trouve à
bruxelles
à bruxelles on l'écouté mesdames
messieurs il est maintenant au moins
20h30 et je crois que je vais devoir
vous quitter car nous avons ce soir à
dîner de travail très important car je
vous rappelle que le très grave problème
du coupage des vins italiens et français
n'a pas encore été résolu
cela risque de nous emmener très tard
dans la nuit
on y passera le temps qu'il faudra mais
on y arrivera je me suis glissé
alors le dialogue n'est pas possible et
pauvre mec sort sous la table à d'areva
ou alors à temps il ya un truc que je
devrais dire avant de commencer toi
parce que moi je suis un mec est
vachement franchement direct toi un truc
que je veux dire c'est pour moi
corneille c'est de la merde
non mais attends tu t'énerves page
s'explique jeudi c'est de la merde parce
que bon premièrement
c'en est un et puis deuxièmement c'est
un truc qui se pose pas sur les
problèmes de jeunes problèmes de couple
et ou de bordel toi alors que moi j'ai
un copain cédule tu le connais dudule
afin de ne pas le connaître
bon eh ben dudule alors lui il n'est pas
connu comme corneille il apprend la
gloire et tout ça ça d'accord à
seulement lui bon premièrement il est
vivant un nom mais déjà au départ ce une
bonne avance et puis deuxièmement il
écrit des trucs tentera pas ce que ça
veut dire
d'ailleurs je vais te dire un de ses
poèmes là là maintenant oui tout de
suite je vais te dire un poème de dudule
à et après je te dirai ton corneille si
tu es sage à on est entre nous ça va
bien se passer et areva
alors j'y vais poème d'un copain alors
je t'explique c'est un poème qu'il avait
écrit à cause d'une anna qu'il était
vachement amoureux d'elle toit et la
nana à s'appeler gisèle alors le poème
il avait appelé gisèle toi le bon j'y
vais poème d'un copain dudule enfin
gisèle enfin bon tu vivais ma femme est
une marque
dur à dire nos merveilleuses ménagères
merveilleuse cuisinière merveilleuse
mère pour les enfants et pourtant ma
petite gisèle c'est toi que je désire
ah bon tu es mieux tant corneille
ok ok ça va j'ai compris bouge pas très
bien où tu es alors je dis ton truc et
je me casse pauvre tu arrives bouge pas
j'y vais quand je regarde auguste au
mieux de sa gloire est une bordel
alors excusez moi je peux pas dire des
trucs comme ça et que vous présentez à
ma triste mémoire mon vieux
mon père excuserait 1 on n'a pas
l'habitude à la maison à massacrer du
trône où je le vois fait le premier
degré et où le trafic non toi je veux
dire moi j'ai déjà vu des trucs qu'on
parce que bon y'a pas besoin de sortir
beaucoup mais alors à ce niveau là c'est
quand même assez rare
moi personnellement je dirais même que
c'est une sorte de record
tu as déjà grillé mec qui jacno comme ça
ta pauvre tard et tu te vois aller
chercher du boulot en parlant comme ça
dites-moi patron chaumes du direct quand
même pas besoin de passer par l'emploi
tarif 2 e
qu'est ce que tu as tu m'as récent à
rennes 1 1
alors t'as pas l'air d'avoir bien qu'au
point où je vais te réexpliqué toi moi
je suis le genre d'individu je te file
une baffe à deux doigts tu sortes des
pompes tu le sais ça
je te souffle dessus tu attrapes une
angine le sait ça alors lâche mal coup
d'une minute et demie et 30 secondes tu
la reverra ta mère est massacrée rejouer
après degrés je m'abandonne tort à vos
ardent transpo mais la di lota
ah bon c'est ça ça va j'ai compris alors
c'est comme partout il y en a qu'on
droit de le dire et puis d'autres pas
c'est ça ok alors t notés toi je te le
dis ta cote monte un je vais déguisée à
la sortie moi tu vas voir le carnaval
voyez vous je partais bien où tu es tu
arrives sacrée ségo c'est pour une mort
les devoirs mille moyens de terminer à
wimille mort ils sont morts c'est la fin
on va porter quoi non le réveillon non
je te dire un truc quand même
taka vraiment du bol mais vraiment du
bol qu'il faut que j'aille faire porter
ma me l'a réparé et te dire un truc
quand même au passage c'est que moi je
suis un film un appareil photo et crois
moi que la photo et les prisons il n'ya
plus qu'à développer ainsi un jour on se
croise dans la balle à samedi soir un
truc comme ça quoi bon ça peut arriver
alors y'a que les montagnes qui se rend
compte pas tu arrives à toi moi je suis
en train de danser avec magie skate
bourgeois tranquille et toi et toi tu
tues tu vas même pas le faire exprès
c'est ça qui est terrible
la destinée un tel atari vêtu ma fleur
coup de boule portefeuille terminé à 100
dans le caniveau tu crois tour
à la sécu direct ya de la place comme je
t'ai dit j'aime à me le team attend
là-bas derrière mais eux un roman crois
moi moi moi tu as la chance
ici au pied il ya quelques ann weiss et
diana s'est couché ya quelqu'un à
bonjour monsieur oui c'est mon chien
alors ça vous dérange
reste la couche est assez au pied bon
alors réputé je tiens je tiens à vous
dire une chose avant de commencer ce pas
je trouve absolument monstrueux mais
monstrueux
la façon dont on est reçu dans ce
théâtre n'est ce pas alors je le devrais
plutôt dire la façon dont on est parti
et ce pas parce que c'est un scandale
alors non on reste là on arrive ici on
est dans le noir la scène n'est même pas
fléché nikolic ex un an mais je me suis
cassé la binette là-haut dans une
gouttière allez savoir comment jeune
homme se trouvait là où c'est à stendhal
taisez vous parlerez aprés mois reste la
gta vous dire une chose malgré tout
c'est que j'ai des relations j'ai le
bras long reste là
on se retrouvera plus tard dans le
métier croyez moi est plutôt que de
penser à comment je le dis tout de suite
oui non se retrouvent rallier crac givet
d'accord allons-y
allez hop on dit que c'est mon heure de
jeu ici on y va je vais temps je regarde
auguste au milieu de sa gloire
patati patata non c'est monstrueux on se
remet comment peut-on vraiment ce que je
continue ou on se retrouvera lié qu'à
massacrer du trône où je le vois ça me
dégoûte mais ça me dégoûte vous
travaillez dans ces monstrueux se
retrouve à l'échographie je je je je ne
sais plus je ne sais plus je me sens
board allez hop et c'était là et c'est
quoi c'est pour une mort si nous sommes
aux autres voiliers crac une mort lui de
voir ce que vous voulez d'ailleurs je
m'en fous complètement
mettons 1000 membres et n'en parlons
plus le satisfait un mois pas je tiens à
vous dire une chose je sais que j'ai
raté mon audition ça je ne sais je tiens
à vous dire une autre chose c'est que
c'est de votre faute
je ne vous dis pas au revoir
ouais
bonjour monsieur le metteur en scène
jean monsieur je m'excuse de 2,2
m'excuser enfin e et de vous demander
par enfin non je vous demande rien je
voulais juste vous dire que je suis venu
pour la l'audition que vous m'avez
demandé
et comme je suis venu et bars je suis là
je suis là parce que je suis venu enfin
bon j'ai donc appris le texte que j'ai
choisi enfin j'ai pas choisi parce que
s'est imposée
et c'est un texte de commencer de de
racine
voilà racines le texte de racine le
texte
non non non c'est pas racine 1 ça y est
c'est l'autre là bas ils sont deux on
dit toujours si c'est pas racine c'est
donc commencer un corner voilà où un ton
en dessous au panneau me je m'excuse je
me cale du givet est tout de suite alors
j'y vais alors là rôle non ça y est ça
commence
le pièce non au petit non à leur rôle
c'est corneille dans emilie de sinon aïe
aïe aïe mes pièces c'est emilie
d'encornets de sinon y'a tout mais
j'arrive pas le
bon écoute et alors moi ce qu'on va
faire un c'est comme j'arrive pas à le
dire et pas je vais le dire enfin me
dire comme je n'arrive pas à dire le
trip le titre je vais dire le fleuve le
le vol c'est de tous les côtés un y à
rien bon j'y vais parce que ça et tout
de suite oui alors quand je regarde
auguste bon il ya sûrement pas bon bah
oui au ban
bon ben moi j'arrête au badge aucune
chance quand même franchement si
moi je veux bien mais ça va recommencer
comme l'année dernière à chaque fois
c'est bon je le dis parce que tout de
suite mais quand je regarde augus et que
vous présentez à ma triste mémoire
mon père massacrer du trône où je le
vois fait le premier degré bon alors moi
qu'est ce que je fais dans sa place à y
est en panne ou alors la jarre et à
celui qui fait que ça c'est valable un
mois j'ai bon je le dis oui pour finir
mais oui pour en finir en baisse
je ne crois plus du tout du tout du tout
malheur encore moins de tout à l'heure
où j'ai passé pour une mort lui de voir
mille morts au moins
il n'y a pas au moins oui au bar
oui leur villa c'est là c'est la fin du
s'est finie
il
ça manque de travail oui pour moi c'est
ce que je dis toujours le travail le
travail seulement on était parti avec
des copains et puis autant de noms pour
écouter alors non ce qu'on va faire
assez vous allait m'envoyer votre photo
ho pardon non non non je m'excuse
monsieur le commissaire monsieur le
monsieur lemay torrance va prendre des
photos et puis on va se les envoyer papa
non écoutez moi je vous dis à bientôt
non bon ou si on se croisait dans un
couloir non plus folles ont alors je
vous dis une autre fois peut-être facile
e
au bon soir je voudrais maintenant
consacrer quelques instants à la poésie
c'est un souvenir personnel ce pas un
soir que je me promenais dans la
campagne
c'était par une nuit sans lune pas les
chiens là-bas au loin boyet dans la
vallée tels que petits oiseaux piailler
encore jean les arbres virgules alors
mon talent à la bref vol
bref un j'ai rencontré sur ma route
n'est ce pas une petite maison
abandonnée genre cabanes de pêcheurs une
maison lier qui n'était pas sans me
rappeler les deux verres que ce écrit le
poète entre deux verres d'alcool fort si
que vous sauve hobbies non nommé li
fille cathy sa peine ce n'est pas pour
vous abbey que vous faites le miel
alors mon bref ouhlala je suis entré
dans cette maison
et c'est là au milieu d'une forêt de
toiles d'araignées ce pas que j'ai
découvert sur le coin de la cheminée un
petit paquet de l'efs fussent pas de
vieilles lettres enrubanné par deux et
jaunis par le temps le temps qui passe
et j'ai ouvert une de ces lettres c'est
celle que je m'en vais vous lire ce soir
alosi alosi à loos il a aussi annoncé
alosi c'était une lettre d'un homme à
une femme gelé tout naturellement
intitulé poèmes d'amour alosi
à quoi bon se déchirer
davantage c'est bien ni hier je crois
que tu me déchire à ma chemise
et puis aujourd'hui mon pantalon et
demain que me déchire ratures non
blouson ça non je ne le supporterai pas
si nous continuons à nous déchirer
davantage nous n'aurons plus rien là à
nous mettre bon alain ridard in stream
oui j'ai bien compris votre question est
bien là mon sens ce qui caractérise ce
temps et quand je dis ce temps c'est le
contenu spatiale du concept temps qui
bien sûr m'intéresse ce qui caractérise
donc à mon avis ce temps ce qui est ce
que j'appellerais son image définition
et vous remarquerez au passage que dans
des finitions il y à des fi etc images
qu'on tient à
c'est la conjonction des pulsions et des
possibles quitte l eau trop chauffer
dans la bassine fait imploser exploser
le couvercle dialectique de l'échaudé
idéologie balayant d'un seul coup d'un
seul grâce aux carburants désir le jeu
le mois et le ca pour atteindre enfin la
seule finalité de l'homme nouveau la
clarté
film de bergman
en
ea ea
on
yako
c'est pas vrai comment vas tu tu vas
bien aux longs mois sera pas du tout ça
va pas c'est pas vrai mais tais toi
qu'est-ce qui se passe bon les tas de
trucs ça va pas je te lis c'est pas vrai
mais tais toi raconte qu'est ce qu'il ya
je pas grave tu regardes autour de toi
ça peut pas aller c'est tout c'est pas
pour arrêter toi mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya
raconte points se penche déjà regarde le
vietnam pour le moyen-orient ce pauvre a
été toi mais raconte qu'est ce qu'il y a
papy c'est pas tout en plus ma femme
c'est pas vrai
tétouan et bien pourtant qu'est-ce qu'il
ya non écoute alors si tu dis c'est pas
vrai et tétouan à tout ce que je te dis
hein moi je te fous mon poing dans la
gueule c'est pas vrai enfin j'ai quand
même un petit espoir c'est vrai je me
dis que si ça s'arrange avec ma femme en
principe le vietnam et le moyen-orient
ça doit suivre
le travail qui longe emma moffatt qui
encore en panique
deux sacs de réparation la semaine
dernière elle est encore en pagne le
pain qui va se prendre dans la tête le
garagiste ça à faire très très mal
c'est pas vrai ça 2 sag a dit donc enfin
heureusement côté coeur là cette fois je
crois que j'ai carrément trouver le
bonheur
ah oui j'ai rencontré une maladie dont
allait super hyper extra c'est un mec
non quand je dis c'est un mec c'est une
façon de parler ou si tu vas méfie-toi
saborit de thaler et saraiva pauvre mec
attend que je te raconte l'histoire tu
essaies hall et aux voltigeurs là-bas à
gambetta
on était en train de se faire une petite
mousse tranquille peinard molopo mchip
et où tu vois juste avant l'arrivée des
agents
et d'un seul coup il ya cette disquette
qui en dit long on aurait vu la classe
de la nana blonde et ou veste de cuir
futal de cuir avec les clous les aigles
et tout le bordel itway d'un allah qui
jette quand même tout de suite et que
c'est quand même assez rare et alors tu
sais toujours ce qui se passe là bas
surtout à gambetta qui l'est c'est leur
père quand même à chaque fois qu'ils
aient une ana qui sera même si tout de
suite les conneries comment vas-tu de
poils des toile d'un matelas comme tu
voitures à bras tu vois n'importe quoi
c'est vrai les nanas sa pelouse foot
c'est normal 1 à l'oral au lieu de ça
les gens tu sais pas ce qui est fait
elle attrape une chaise comme ça et à
fait eu il ya quelqu'un qui est pas
content là dedans il ya un mec dans le
fond au lieu de s'écraser mollo pomme
chip est toutefois de roupiller
tranquillo spénard dans son coin le tard
et il lève le doigt d'ide au lieu de
travail à coup de genou dans le vide le
pif écrasé deux yeux au beurre noir
le mec qui s'est retrouvé par terre les
moustaches en croit seul cas où il a
failli souffler son gaz
oui oui gahler a été tellement énergique
a commencé fli des grands coups de
pompes au maire
ma pompe qui encore déchirée dans un sac
de réparation la semaine dernière elle
est encore déchiré le pain qui va se
prendre dans la tête le marchand de
chaussures ça va faire très très mal à
ses ports et noir le garagiste et le
marchand de pompe ils vont être jumeaux
la semaine bref je reviens à mon
histoire c'est cette anam avait
vachement atterrissez mois
bon c'est vrai c'est normal parce que tu
vas quand même plus souvent des mecs qui
castagne d'émettre moins fort que que
des nanas qui chie corps des mecs c'est
vrai c'est plus rare dans l'ancien alors
moi je me suis dit celle-là il ya pas le
problème il faut que j cause plus sa
tombe est vachement bien parce que
j'étais super bien ça paie enfin moi je
trouve
j'avais les ray ban je vais la chemise à
quoi la bague avec la tête de mort la
matraque soupe la chaîne de vélo tout le
bordel
alors je me suis ramené à côté d'elle
comme ça et je les regardais eu presque
dans les yeux toi
j'y fais comment ça va baby là tu me
crois où tu me crois pas là la nama fil
d'une tard j'ai fait quatre tours et
demi nous je me suis retrouvé par terre
c'est tout juste si j'étais pas sorti de
mes baskets non mais tu vois un peu la
gêne devant les copains pour le travail
chez et puis quoi fertonne où il fallait
bien que je me relève parce que tu
comprends la sueur ça dure qu'un temps
1 alors je me suis relevé doucement je
les regardais comme ça vachement western
gif et consorts me fais ok et dans les
sorties c'est quand on est arrivés sur
le trottoir toi moi j'avais eu le temps
de réfléchir je me suis dit quand même
qu'on est un maître une nana il ya
d'autres moyens de se fendre la gueule
que de ce chic oreilles c'est vrai
j'ai dit on va faire un tout à me fais
ok alors on a sauté sur mon arlette un
non c'est pas vraiment une année c'est à
dire c'est une mob ordinaire que j'ai
rajouté un guidon style harley mais pour
la france est suffisant tu peut frimer
avec ça alors on a roulé roulé roulé
roulé roulé on s'est retrouvé au moins
je crois c'est porte maillot toi tu es
là on s'est arrêté et on a causé est
très très très vite on a compris que on
étaient faits l'un pour l'autre
surtout moi d'ailleurs moi j'ai dit je
trouve ça vachement chouette el ahmadi
qui a trouvé ça chouette aussi bref on
était déjà de a trouvé ça chouette hein
et puis on s'est aperçu très vite qu'on
avait les mêmes idées sur la vie c'est
quand même vachement important quand on
est un couple d'avoir les mêmes idées
sur la vie question entendre du couple
et tous sains et le coup classique qui
se passe toujours quand et avec une
disquette que tu as les mêmes idées
qu'elle sur la vie thouet tu as envie
d'y rouler une pelle et crac bonjour
madame on sait rouler une pelle porte
maillot
et depuis c'est carrément le zew bonheur
un nom là les prologues parce que louer
thaï ha non c'est pas qu'il ya des
problèmes bon s'il ya c'est que tu te
rends compte d'une nana qui chie quand
les mecs c'est pas toujours une à la
facilité aux grands elle est très très
chef comme d'un attrait très autoritaire
selon moi j'ai dit méfie-toi méfie toi
je me laisserais pas monté sur les
embryons non mais sans blague
qu'est ce que croient qu'on peut pas se
passer d'elle non mais peut être attrapé
un procès d'els mois à 10,2 perdu une de
retrouvée non mais
vous dire ça comme l'autre fois laquelle
a pas voulu venir au cinéma avec moi là
moi je suis allé tout seul
et puis ça a rien changé parce que le
film il était aussi bien
c'est aussi dire vont ces appareils
tymoschuk aussi à s'élancer vendredi que
son prodige eux pourraient servir aux
plus patients peuvent ainsi pu à leur
nom mois joue pas ici alors c'est pas
egidio pas tient aux jeux conçus m'ont
dit je pense yati je rendis à siwel et
ouais non non moi je suis toujours si
j'ai pas dis je le dis je prends tu as
dis et je vais bosser c'est ainsi tirer
mon lait par agences intesa c'est du
bonbon
je vais ainsi jambon de vinci mais en
changeant laisser en vie et quand le
rallye actually échangé au cse et quand
je vois la dir ont changé paribas bon
s'il vous plaît alors
et quant à l'ancien valencien récemment
changé
non non non ça n'existe pas avec moi là
et a pris de ce mode et je me suis dit
je te dis voilà pour les jeunes aux
artistes un peu moins 10 g messieurs
nautique que j'ai pu aussi jeudi au
procès à l'enjeu du rni j étais elle est
allée est allé non s'il vous plaît
l'assuré tu allais aller oui pas de
problème j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit
ap affronteront bons et loyaux services
et des tensions à dire changer les
voiles océan qui seront ravis
aujourd'hui j'ai aussi non sur scipion
jésus a dit jeudi la radio voit son mât
rares
mélenchon sénateur gillot ce mardi
[ __ ] pour le riz rond
yamoo sais pas si c'est pas inquiet
c'est au moins 10
je m'excuse c'est moi qui parle rouge à
six parties
enfin non je suis parti je me suis à 10
10 euros la carte verte s'il vous plaît
c'est la carte verte et passionnant dit
je n'ai pas être pas si la carte verte
alors là moi je suis pas si je vais pas
changer la carte vierge on m'a dit j'ai
pas si ces jouisseurs rouge mais aussi
pour son jeu sont si jeunes voici la
carte verte va dire aux gens que je suis
mais je ne situe pas là si je pense pas
c'est pire ce n'est pas elle m'a dit je
pense aussi à giscard d'estaing
et alors c'est que je suis là aussi
rouge vert je vais à dire giscard
d'estaing jogo tout le monde m'en suis
un gentil genre on sera six jeunes
anciens amis et puis j'ai dit au revoir
et puis je suis parti
mademoiselle mademoiselle s'il vous
plaît mademoiselle manoise mademoiselle
ses démons c'est dingue dingue down ses
démons dément dément dément dément
dément c'est de pire en pire ça
s'aggrave tous les jours et personne
n'en parle
et bien moi je dis halte stop ça suffit
comme ça basta cosi moi je vais te dire
hein c'est pas grave mais si on veut
guérir le mal il faut le mettre au grand
jour
moi je vais le dire il n'ya plus d'amour
en france surtout chez les femmes ah je
sais ça fait mal ça fait très mal mais
c'est la vérité
et moi qui voyage beaucoup à l'étranger
je sais de quoi je parle
bon déjà lorsque je travaillais en
france je m'étais bien aperçu que de ce
côté là du côté des femmes
il y avait quelque chose qui clochait
des choses que l'on peut vous lancer non
ou alors c'est à vous tous ça touche pas
un [ __ ] voyeur
les signes avant-coureurs du mal si vous
voulez mais je me disais bon elles sont
en crise est une période sa valeur passé
depuis que je voyage à l'étranger pour
mon travail
là je suis formelle il n'y a plus
d'amour en france surtout chez les
femmes
ensuite les femmes de france à fumer
c'est sûr tenez un exemple sans aller
chercher le bout du monde
l'autre jour j'étais à evian france
je marchais vers les 10 11 heures du
soir sur les rives du lac à l'oeuvre la
lune la brume le lac une bonne douzaine
de grenouilles
oui enfin tout pour le sentiment quoi
inopinément je croise une jeune fille
blonde en jean à qui marchait d'un pas
vif mais alerte et dans ce merveilleux
paysages je m'approche d'elle soir alors
on se promène bon écoute max jumelage
parce que moi je sors de l'usiné était
déco non j'ai pas que ça à m'envoyer à
voilà la femme française on ne parle que
boulot alors que le lendemain à la même
heure avec la même l'une la même brume
mais de l'autre côté en suisse pas en
france je croise une jeune personne
superbe grande brune un très joli petit
sac
m
je les petits sacs habillé tout en
panthère non mais déjà rien que ça ça
montre un effort pour plaire à oui c'est
pas le jean délavé et ben appel j'allais
lui adresser la parole qu'elle me dit tu
prends un verre
je n'invente rien la même l'une la même
brume le même lac mais pas en france
c'est tout parce qu'en france il n'y a
pas d'amour surtout chez les femmes et
pour ne me dise pas que ça vient noir un
que je ne fais pas d'effort que je me
désintéresse faux pas à moi non
messieurs tenait encore la semaine
dernière j'ai consacré un samedi entier
aux jeunes françaises j'étais assis à la
terrasse du café de la paix et bien si
je n'ai pas proposé à dix jeunes filles
de venir au cinéma avec moi je n'ai pas
proposé à une va te faire [ __ ]
connard
c'était leur grand mot ah non non ils
vont mal elles vont mal très très mal
bon tout n'est pas foutu c'est vrai pari
n'est tout de même pas le désert
intégrale de l'amour c'est vrai moi même
l'autre jour en passant rue saint denis
j'ai eu une petite aventure où une jeune
fille charmante au demeurant enfin rien
de bien sérieux moss aurait pu être une
liaison si j'avais voulu un et bien vous
me croirez si vous voulez elle n'était
pas française c'est quand même
malheureux que ce soit les étrangères
qui donne l'exemple
alors après on se plaint que les
touristes ne viennent plus en france
allez petite femme les petites femmes
les petites femmes de paris oui eh ben
non elles sont pas de paris elles sont
chez eux alors ils restent chez eux
non non non quand je pense à toutes ces
filles qui savait mais qui ont le coeur
sous la main bangkok mexico hambourg
tenez encore il ya un mois à athènes
cette petite femme de chambre que j'ai
retrouvé dans mon lit amoureuse et si
merveilleusement tendre qui non
seulement m'a donné de l'amour pendant
toute une nuit
mais aussi m'a donné le bonheur de
pouvoir aider les miséreux les la la
joie si la joie que j'ai eue le matin en
lui donnant les 2500 francs 2500 francs
qu'elle me demandait pour sa vieille
mère
il vivait depuis près de 50 ans dans une
grotte sans eau ni électricité
c'était une joie infinie merci mélina
non vraiment par moments moins
franchement j'ai envie de tout larguer
et d'aller m'installer là-bas à
l'étranger seulement aussi des types
comme moi quitte définitivement la
france
il y aura plus jamais d'amour en france
surtout chez les femmes alors c'est pour
ça j'essaye encore je me balade
mademoiselle benoît z
qu'est ce que vous faites à midi alors à
6 heures bon ce soir et demain
nicole nicholl nicholl c'est fini je bon
nicole je peux je peux parler je peux
parler je je je peux parler alors qu'est
ce que tu veux que je te dise je crois
que
tu as tout dit et que tout est dit et
que on s'est tous dit et que partant de
là on n'a plus rien à se dire
surtout après tout ce qu'on vient de se
dire - ya comme une dernière chose que
je voudrais te dire c'est que tu prends
ta valise est tu fous l'camp
car prix tu prends l'ascenseur le
pouvoir à gauche étant tué dans la rue
tu prends un taxi tu mets tout ça tu
dors tu fous l'camp je te quitte
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on aurait dû
commencer ce qu'ils étaient avant de se
connaître
seulement je te connaissais pas alors tu
avais la partie facile à n'ont pas de
gestes inutiles le temps pris c'est fini
ça suffit comme ça
après un point fini comment le point sur
le i ah oui c'est très drôle oui assez
bien moment de faire de l'humour après
après la vie tu m'as fait mener alors
maintenant tu embarques tout et tu
dégages pas compris ton pick up et à
raquettes de tennis où ça tu regardes
tous à aller circulation et puis que
possible oui aussi aller tout ça et la
raquette vas-y la raquette le pick up et
la raquette
et n'oublie pas la raquette tient des
photographies aussi tu lui donneras
jérôme ce nom
quoi oui il m'a peut-être foutu 6-0 au
tennis mais c'est 1 1 quand même et puis
si on l'avait pas mis un fils et une
pompe ça serait peut-être passer
autrement
allez allez circulation et puis en
passant t'oublie pas non plus tu as
librairie diététique la régime pour 6
régime pour ça est ceci et cela alors
que s'il y en avait un ici qui devait
faire le régime
c'était moi oui bon à leur écoute
alors là tu reprends ta valise laporte
l'ascenseur le couloir la rue le taxi et
tu dégages
voilà allez circulation ciao bye bye
sayonara
ical c'est fini allez vas tu
nicole attend attend une dernière chose
que je devrais te dire c'est que tu ne
retrouveras jamais un type comme moi et
espère bien bon alors
bon alors écoute alors là tu prends ta
valise et bon tu te débrouilles tout
seul je t'indique mais plus chemin à
lyon
allez moi j'essaye qu'on se quitte bons
amis intelligemment que même s'il n'y a
plus d'amour entre nous il reste au
moins un pieu dans un peu d'amitié
1 et toi tu m'insultes alors maintenant
tu t'embarques aller dehors
quoi comment le poisson quel poisson à
le poisson rouge
théodore et ben théodore il est très
bien ici dans son bocal 1 il est même
tellement bien qui va rester ici
voilà je le garde théodore reste ici
quoi c'est pas juste
ah oui c'est la mère qui a la garde du
poisson rouge peut-être et ben justement
théodore n'est plus un enfant c'est un
adulte alors même que si je serais très
très bien mon équipe
comment mais c'est une pincée de une
demi pain c'est de commencer enfin bon
tout les tous les matins tous les soirs
oui et puis changer l'eau tous les
oui enfin bon je me débrouillerai
théodore reste ici et toi aussi
et toi aussi bon ben alors seulement une
journée 1
mais qu'on soit bien d'accord si tu
restes c'est uniquement pour t'occuper
du poisson mais deux jours mais pas plus
de trois jours alors bon ben alors tu
renvoies ton taxi tu reviens sur tes pas
tu prend le couloir à droite l'ascenseur
tu sors et là la porte sera ouverte
tu rentres et tu la fermes
non je parle de la porte
écoutant n'a pas recommencé non